welcome back everybody holiday shopping
is officially
in season and a great deal is for
everybody right whether you're shopping
on a budget
or not fabulous lifestyle expert amy
sewell is here to help you
i'm so excited to talk holiday sales and
gifts this year because we finally made
it we all need the holiday cheer
yeah and the deals definitely started
early this year so
i worked with several companies to put
together some ideas bed bath and beyond
have some amazing deals to take you
through the season
now on black friday and the saturday
after thanksgiving you get
25 off your entire in-store purchase
no coupons no beyond plus membership
required
and this even includes online orders
that you place for
the pickup either in store or curbside
now they have a lot of items that you
could pick up for yourself or for gifts
i love these items from their artisanal
kitchen supply collection i think
they're just really elegant pieces to
have
now with bed bath and beyond you can
shop in store
you could also order online for that
free in-store or curbside pickup
and through december 24th they have a
holiday daily deal on their website so
check all those things out and find some
really great savings this year
what kind of jewelry gifts are out there
what kind of deals can we get on jewelry
hullsberg has some fabulous deals on
gifts under 600 and these are nice for
your mistletoe worthy moments this
season
i especially love the three-piece blue
sapphire and diamond set you see here
this is a pendant ring and earrings in
10 karat white gold
for 599.99 you can also find a great
deal on this lightheart 3 8 carat
lab-grown diamond bar necklace this is
300
off so it's only
you could also do 399.99 for pickup
either curbside or in-store
just check out helzberg.com to find more
details about those and
other gifts that sparkle i love gifts
that sparkle but i also love gifts that
we can interact and play with so what
kind of games do you have
yeah well gamestop this year has the
oculus quest 2
which is the most advanced all-in-one
virtual reality system now this starts
at 299.
it's also the great place to go to get
some fun collectibles now gamestop is
the only place
to find these cyberpunk funko pop
figures from the new game release
these are 11.99 each and i think that
makes a great stocking stuffer
for people now i know a lot of people
who would absolutely love
the star wars the mandalorian and i love
this animatronic figure here
it's 59.99 and you can find this in
gamestop
now gamestop you can shop either in
store online or through their
mobile app then you can pick up your
order either in store or through their
delivery at door service
you can find more information about all
these items and their pre-black friday
deals
at gamestop.com gift hub perfect and
those are perfect gifts for adults and
kids
exactly now i see a beautiful flag on
the wall what's that about
well this is a beautiful patriotic gift
that is also made in the usa
this is from metal art of wisconsin and
if you take a close look at this you'll
see
the wood is actually slightly burned and
hand oiled then the steel
is actually inlaid into the wood so this
is a beautiful piece that would look
great anywhere in the house
now from now through christmas you get
20 off site wide
at metalart of wisconsin.com when you
enter the code tv20 at checkout if you
want to get this in time for christmas
though go ahead and place your order
all other items are handmade so it takes
a few weeks for delivery but
as you can see it's definitely worth the
wait
for more information visit
shopwithstyle.com kendall i'll send it
over to you